Hi, guys, can I be your friend?
Can I write on your wall?
No.
Will you be my friend?
But I write on all my friends' walls.
I think I would have to know you before I was your friend.
All my friends have got like 180 friends.
I've only got two.
Yeah?
Would it help if maybe you'd look through my photos?
And that one is with two really pretty girls.
That's my ex.
I was in a relationship with her but I've changed my status now.
What's your relationship status?
Single.
Okay, cool. I like that.
Do you?
Yeah.
Good.
I like your jacket.
Thank you.
I like your sunglasses.
Do you like that?
No.
Do you want to comment on that?
I like your Ray-Bans.
Could I poke you?
Poke?
Poke.
No?
Ah, no.
But poke?
Poke?
What, do you want to poke?
Can I poke you?
Yeah, you can poke me if you want.
Nah.
No dude seriously, just be my friend.
If I just show you these pictures in this photo album.
Alright, so you use Twitter?
Yeah.
I'm gonna follow you.
Okay.
Cool, cool.
Well, I'm gonna follow you.
Right, okay.
Thanks a lot, nice one. Thanks guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Wicked, wicked.
Bye! Cheers! Wicked.
Alright, thank you. That's great.
Wicked. Thanks a lot. Bye.
Oh, you're actually following me.
I'm following you.
Twitter!